you mentioned that you wanted to talk
game sooner with people you could look
back where do you think would have been
the right time to start getting kind of
game savvy yeah I I probably should have
done it after like once hams was kind of
the HOH so that would have been my
second week in the house because I was
immune the first week yeah that should
have been my opportunity especially
knowing that he wasn't gonna put me up I
knew Oh safe that week that should have
been my time to really go at it in from
a game perspective and I didn't do that
but I don't know I was just really
enjoying all of the music and yeah just
yeah I felt like I was HOH it's very
fair enough you did kind of seem like a
bit of an outsider because of the fact
that you again had the social strategy
but didn't have the game play quite down
pat did you ever feel like an outsider
in the house yeah for sure
I I did feel like that just kind of
walking around and a lot of people have
like they were there were a lot of twos
in that house like there's people were
paired with certain people and you know
when you don't have that you do feel you
do feel alone from times and at time
sorry and yeah I I definitely did feel
that way and it sucks but it's part of
the game just got to keep going not
gonna complain about it you were up on
the Block three times in a row I you
kind of were the default pond of the
house who do you think is gonna be the
next target to succeed you then the next
target to succeed me I feel like will is
also really good with everybody so
that's kind of I was telling him it was
like man once I'm gone
you will be that person you know I tried
to warn him and he clearly didn't like
to hear that but I it's either I feel
like Ryan Ryan also could be that person
as well Ryan or well I feel this would
would be the the next person to be kind
of being put on the Block a lot
do you think Erica because she talked a
lot about having this target having won
a lot of comps and been HOH and stuff
about being this threat do you think
that that will eventually hurt her yes I
think she's getting drunk in her power I
felt it and I was just kind of like
she's like yeah I've won all these comes
I'm like yeah good job great that's
great keep it up keep that confidence up
but I was like girl you need to stop but
I was gonna tell her that I wanted her
to keep doing it I wanted her to feel as
powerful as possible cuz you like you
will have a glimpse of power in that
house and then the next week it's all
gone you can not win HOH and then not
get picked for veto if you're not
nominated and then you literally have
zero influence like and I that's why
things can change so quickly in that
house so I for her own sake she should
stop but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna be
the one to tell her that cuz I don't
care well especially with the goodbye
message that she gave you and said that
you were she can't play chess with a
board full of pawns what do you think of
that yeah it's funny but like I don't
know I don't care I don't really care to
be honest with you see she's I I can't
see oh yeah it was a little salty I'm
not gonna lie I gonna see here and act
like it didn't bother me a little bit
but at the end of the day like I I I
can't see her making it to final two as
I she's a strong player but again like
that she's putting a target on her back
so um I don't know it good luck to Erica
I don't know I don't really care well
having said now who do you think could
be the one to take it I I think I think
Johnny can take it I'll go with Johnny
just because he's he is capable of
winning competitions and his social game
is incredible everybody loves him in
that house super funny Cho guy I think
he has the best chance right now but
things can change very fast I don't
think people out home realize how
quickly things change so it's it's
almost impossible at this point to say
okay this
it's impossible do you want him to win I
yeah more than others for sure I would
also love for Paris to do as well to do
well I love that girl but yeah I'll draw
any more than others for sure in Paris